Nancy Lieberman who is a basketball hall
of famer assistant coach with the
sacramento kings and Nance kind enough
to join us Nance good morning thanks for
joining us give people an idea of Pat
Summitt the person we know the coach but
was she the same kind of person as she
was as a coach he was very humble for
everything that she had obtained and
done in her career as a player and
approach when I was good enough so I
mean she'd be cooking up a storm for
people you know my son TJ and mt j & and
tyler would be playing with pokemon
cards they'd be on little those
motorized jeeps playing in the yard and
we were just being a kitchen cooking I
mean that's the side of Pat another side
of Pat that I know but can you imagine
me being her teammate at 15 and really
not knowing where I belong on that
Olympic team because I was so much
younger and Pat would just kind of plop
in my room talk to me you'll walk with
me on the court uh you know she would
also tell me how important my role is
even though like I was the you know the
12th man on the 76 Olympic team I
remember her saying you're going to be
the 12th man here but you're going to be
the man in the future of women's
basketball and I didn't know what she
meant in 76 but he just gave me so much
toughness shall we should be humble no
matter what you do you'll be a great
teammate and he knows he'll destroy all
the time where anytime something major
happened to me in my career whether it
was coaching in the WNBA or coaching
men's basketball I would pick up the
phone and I call her i say what do you
think and she was to say you'd have to
do this with Donnie Nelson hired me
she's like Nancy you have to do this and
she was kind of my my you know checks
and balances throughout my career I
mentioned
the importance of Pat Summitt I didn't
think I was overstating it I mentioned
that you know dr. Naismith invented this
and you know put the peach basket up
with the ladder there but she was that
two women's basketball the importance of
Pat Summitt to women's athletics as well
can you sum that up yes I can because
when she started at Tennessee and
Tennessee you know started winning
championships in 87 then go back in
history and find out how many times Pat
summit scheduled a game at the other
guys court to help build their program
she did it for TCU he did it for Sarah
Cole he did it for UConn she did it for
everybody you know there's no stat line
for helping somebody you know change how
women's basketball is perceived and I'll
never forget you know we won the
back-to-back national championships at
Old Dominion and he looked at me and she
says we have to do this we have to have
a sold-out crowd like you guys do at Old
Dominion and she used old dominion as
kind of her measuring stick of how she
wanted Tennessee to be and then she just
took it to a whole nother level I just
remember the intimidation factor when I
was hosting the sports illustrated'
sportsman in the year award a couple
years ago and it was Mike sous-chefs key
and Pat Summitt I had no problem walking
up to Coach K I didn't want to walk up
to Pat Summitt she intimidated me I
didn't want that look Nance you knew
where you stood with her ok so we're
Team 1876 we win the silver medal and he
USA basketball says to her we want you
to coach your first USA team it was the
junior national team and I'm in my
apartment at Old Dominion I had just
finished my freshman year and Pat calls
me and she was Nancy I need for you to
do me a favor and I said yes ma'am cuz I
need for you to play on the junior team
for me because I know you can play on
the varsity you've earned that right but
I could really use you on the JV denies
it
okay no problem and she would always
thank me for not going to the national
team and playing on the junior national
team for her and I was coming out of the
locker room one day in Mexico were
playing Brazil and son playing against
Hortensia and they both think we're the
best players in the world and I come out
of the locker room and Pat pushes me up
against the wall with her middle finger
and puts it on my chest and she was me
at the government tell many rebounds did
you ever did Old Dominion and I was ten
and she was you haven't had 10 rebounds
in two weeks and if you don't get a 10
rebounds in the second half I'm putting
you on a plane tomorrow well you can ask
Holly Warlick I beat the crap out of my
teammates in the second half and that
every rebound because he was
nose-to-nose with me and I was so scared
it's just she pushed you to places you
didn't think you could go but she was
amazing I told the story first our dance
just a little bit when we were in dallas
playing the pickup game and Deion
Sanders was playing ken norton jr and i
said Nance was the best player on the
floor and the reason why I bring this up
is Deion just admitted that he was close
to trying to play for the Atlanta Hawks
back when he was in Atlanta and I'm
thinking you were the best player on the
floor that day and that was with Dion
and some of the other Dallas Cowboys you
remember that I do we were playing at
the signature club and you were staying
with us and that was fun I mean those
those are very real real moments for
forward Dayton Flyers oh you were a bad
ass on the floor though man you like it
you were hidden guys in the head because
they you were throwing passes that magic
johnson would have applauded I was
playing because people like Muhammad
influence influence my life people like
Pat influenced my life and quite frankly
I leave you know Dan we've been friends
a long time I was just a street kid from
New York just trying to survive and that
was the only way I knew how and you guys
put up with me and going um I'm so
thankful I've had such a great life but
you know we're
losing so many of these icon I mean from
being at Mohamed's funeral a couple
weeks ago to now past and to be quite
honest you know they called me Saturday
and said you need to get out here and I
booked a flight sunday to go to
Knoxville and then they call me sunday
night in San Nancy you can't come out
here you know hospice is saying
everybody has to leave because Pat won't
go Pat refuses to die because she knows
so many so many people are wanting to
see her and it's just you know RB and
tyler and and miss a diesel her mother
and she just needed to be by herself and
here she is and finally she found some
peace but you know i mean i love the
lady that's a great story great story um
so mhm well I appreciate you joining us
and yeah I know it's a tough time but
but I I'm glad for the memory so I'm
glad that you have some things you can
share to the audience dance so thank you
for joining us thank you for having me
on and I appreciate you so much the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience